MICHAEL FINK: My name is Michael
Fink, and I'm the
product manager Google Chart
Tools, which is the team
within Google that's responsible
for building
visualization tools both for
Google products and for the
external developer community.
And before I start,
I want to--
this is a talk about data
visualization and live data
visualization.
So we want to collect live data
from you guys and use
that data in heard order to
present all of the great tools
that our team has
been building in
the last two months.
Now we're going to collect data
using a game, which we
call The Unique Game.
So what I need is, actually,
open your laptops, which
you've probably already done.
And I'll tell you a bit
about the rules of
this very simple game.
So The Unique Game is a game
where each and everyone of you
should choose a number,
a natural number.
And so far it's fairly easy.
And you have to choose a number
that you will be the
only person that will choose
that number, OK?
So it still sounds
fairly easy.
And the last rule, which puts
in the twist, is that the
winner will be the person that
chooses the lowest, unique
natural number.
So I'll let you ponder
on that for a second.
And I'd like you to go into this
URL here on the bottom,
io2011charts.
And we need each and every one
of you to participate in this
game, because otherwise we won't
have data to visualize.
And now, what you can see here,
is once you enter that
URL, you'll see this
small form.
Let me put in some data, so I
think that the lowest number
will probably five.
OK, and I could put in my email
because the person that
will win will get
a grand prize.
And I won't tell
you, all right?
And I'm exposing my email here,
but that's great so you
could feel free to send
me emails later on.
And I'll submit it.
And what you see here, on the
bottom right is a gauge that
should be reflecting
the number of
votes that we're receiving.
Is there like a severe
connectivity issue?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
MICHAEL FINK: OK, so we just
killed live, and we'll stay
with data visualization
without live.
If half of the demos that we're
planning will still
work, we'll be happy
with that.
So what we have here
is this live gauge.
What's nice about these slides
is that all visualizations
that you'll see are essentially
embedded
into this HTML page.
And all of the slides are
essentially one HTML file that
we'll make accessible
later down the road.
And you'll be able to pull it,
and take a look at all of the
source code behind what
we're presenting.
So The Unique Game, maybe if
you've written down the URL
and if connectivity comes back
later on, you could try and
fill it up.
So as I said, my name
is Michael Fink,
I'm the product manager.
And what we're going to talk
about today is data
visualization and a lot of great
tools that our team has
been building in the
last few months.
And the climax of the talk
will be in a short
demonstration on how you can
create full interactive
dashboards, using the tools
that we've built.
Now the talk will be composed
of two parts.
The first part will be called,
charts for everyone, and I'll
be delivering that
part, AKA fluff.
No actual code there.
And then the second part will
be delivered by our two tech
leads: Riccardo and Amit.
And that will be a
hands-on session.
And if we still don't have
connectivity, it will be a
virtual hands-on session.
And they will be covering how
to use charts in the context
of app scripts.
They will be talking about our
new ChartWrapper, which is a
new syntax for very simply
writing and spec'ing out a
chart, and serializing
it later on.
They'll be talking about our new
chart editor, and how you
could embed a full chart editor
into your website.
And then Riccardo will conclude
with an introduction
to controls and dashboards,
which will explain how to use
multiple charts and multiple
controls into creating a full
data exploration experience.
Now if you look up out on a few
efforts that Google has
gone into in the last few years,
you could see that in a
very systematic way, we took
domains that were specialized
domains to experts, and we
try to democratize them.
So we've done that with map
maker, and democratizing
cartography, so suddenly
everyone could
create his own map.
And we've done that
with YouTube, and
democratizing video.
So, until a few years ago, if
you wanted to have any chance
to have a video that reaches
millions of people, you had to
probably work in a studio
in Hollywood.
And today, you could sit for
one afternoon, and make a
viral video, and suddenly
that capability is
available for everyone.
And we've democratized 3D
modeling, using Google
SketchUp other tools.
And what I want to challenge us
as a community, is can we
democratize data
visualization?
Can we make the process of data
visualization something
that everyone could do in
an effortless manner?
So how many people are familiar
with this chart?
OK, that's all the XKCD
readers here, great.
So what's nice about
this chart--
it kind of explains our
motivation in democratizing
data visualization is the fact
that one chart is often worth
1,000 images.
And this beautiful chart
explains why the gravity wells
are in our solar system.
And you can see that it nicely
explains in that small box why
going from a very low well, like
Earth, all the way to the
moon requires a fairly
big rocket.
But if you want to return from
the moon back to Earth, you
need a very small rocket,
because you the only barrier
that you have to pass
is the small gravity
barrier of the moon.
So a nice visualization, a
nice chart, could really
communicate a lot
of information.
And we were inspired by the
work of Randall Munroe and
XKCD over the last recent years,
by observing how time
and time again Randall was able
to create different chart
types and different
visualizations that we were
all familiar with, but give
them a new flavor.
So he's been using
scatter plots.
And you can see a scatter
plot here to the left.
The y-axis is whether
the fruit is tasty.
The x-axis is how difficult or
easy it is to eat that fruit.
And does anyone know what this
scatter plot was titled?
"Fuck Grapefruit."
Now let's understand why: so
grapefruit is all the way here
on the bottom because it's
difficult and un-tasty, OK?
And you have seedless grapes
here in the top, because
they're easy and tasty.
Grapes with pits are
not that easy.
And one visualization, one
scatter plot can really
communicate a lot
of information.
He's been using bar charts
along the years.
This is a bar chart that shows
that a lot more people search
for the sentence, I should have
kissed her, rather than,
I shouldn't have kissed her.
And I won't even go into this
heat map down here.
Oops, I'm trying to switch
a slide, but.
Are we stuck on this slide?
Let me try to refresh, maybe?
Complete browser crash.
OK, perfect now.
Everyone close your eyes for
three seconds, so you won't
have to see the entire talk.
OK perfect.
So taking these great examples
as inspiration, we defined our
team's mission to make the
world's structured data
universally accessible and
useful using visualizations.
And our motif is to try to build
charts that could be
used by anyone.
And anyone, we mean like the
end-users, the end-consumers,
that we might be dealing with,
developers such as yourself,
people that work in the apps
and enterprise contexts.
So we really tried to build set
of tools that anyone could
use, and I'll try to
demonstrate that.
So let's start from consumers.
We view consumers as people that
don't write code at all.
So we want something that
is complete UI based.
And if you want to create
a chart, and that's the
limitation that you have to
start with, then we provide,
within Google Spreadsheets,
a set of charts.
Here's the spreadsheet that
actually connects--
oh I see that a lot of people
did manage to respond.
So here all of the responses
that we got.
Who provided 65,000?
Guys, you're way off.
And here's a short histogram
of the actual selection.
So we see that 20 people--
the smart-asses--
chose one.
And if I just want
to add a chart, I
select the data range.
And I could get a chart
with one click.
And this new chart editor that
we've created is very cleverly
done, in a way that if you
select a data range, we
observe the data and try to
filter out, or prioritize the
charts that are best compatible
with the data rage
that the user has selected.
And so that's one feature
of this chart editor.
And you know, you could easily
switch over to customize it,
or select a different flavor,
you know, if you want to
change different colors,
you want to
change the legend position.
All of these are options that
could be easily done.
So even as a consumer, you're in
a position where you could
really, in a very quick
manner, provide data
visualization that was
not available.
But that's obviously less
exciting for the audience
here, and what's more exciting
is the offering that we have
for developers.
So what's nice about Google
Chart Tools is that we have--
and this is an advanced talk,
so I assume that most of you
are familiar with our tools.
So I'll just glance through
it, and assume that you're
familiar with this stack.
But Google Chart Tools provide
a very rich gallery of charts
and visualizations that
you've already seen.
But we also provide a common
data structure, which we call
the data table that all
visualizations work over that
same data table.
So if you want to switch between
visualizations, since
they all work over the same data
structure, that's a very
simple task.
And there are a lot of utilities
over that data
table, where, if you want to
create views, or add rows on
the fly, all of these
are things that you
could very easily do.
And then we have even a deeper
layer that goes back to the
data sources that you might
have. And we also provide some
built-in data sources, like
Google Spreadsheets, and
Fusion Tables, and others,
that could hook
up into your data.
And we provide Java and Python
libraries that help you hook
up your data and layout in
back end to the actual
visualizations that you want
to [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
So we really provide an entire
stack of the tools.
And what I want to talk about a
bit is kind of give you the
highlights, and what's
new in the stack.
So what we've had it for a while
already is the option to
customize charts.
So this is a very important
thing for developers, is make
sure that we have very coherent
experience with the
general site.
This is a great pie chart that
tries to convey the fact that
the ninja turtle, Michelangelo,
right now is
more popular, or is searched
more in Google, than the
actual Renaissance artist.
So the green slice is
Michelangelo, the ninja turtle,
and the brown one is
Michelangelo, the artist.
And you can see that this is
the XKCD original, and you
know, with two very simple
options, you could say, oh,
put the legend in the bottom.
Make sure that the colors are
this shade of green, and
here's the appropriate
shade of brown.
And voila, I have the customized
chart that I could
take and plug into my website.
Another demonstration of
customization is--
so here's that stacked area
chart of the gravity wells
that we saw earlier on.
And here's the version that you
will get if you use the
visualizations out of the box.
And say this is not really
working for you.
You don't really need the grid
lines, you don't really need
the numbers on the
x- and y- axes.
You definitely don't like this
color palette, so you could
easily customize pretty much
anything that you want and
make sure that it fits nicely
into your website.
By the way, quick question,
what's our favorite moon in
the solar system?
Io.
Very good.
OK cool.
So those are things that were
available for a while and then
on the new stuff is we're fully
committed to switching
over to HTML5.
And people here that are
familiar with our gallery know
that we still had some flash
visualizations in our gallery.
And we are pretty much in the
process of phasing them out
and coming out with new versions
that are completely
HTML5 compatible.
You could see this GeoMap here
on the top of the chart, which
is purely SVG-based.
And what we see in this charge
is the gradual popularity
overtime of Dilbert
versus XKCD.
So how many people here have
ever read Dilbert?
A nice crowd.
How many people have
ever read XKCD?
Everyone, no?
I don't know, I always assumed
that that was the case.
So what we can do now is we can
see over time, we can see
that way back in 2006 there
was no XKCD, right?
And Dilbert was pretty much a
common thing, specifically
around California which is a
Silicon Valley stronghold.
And then around 2008
XKCD came in.
And I think Randall Munroe
started from Massachusetts.
And you could see that he had
his followers develop there.
And by today, XKCD is
a lot more popular
than Dilbert worldwide.
So what's nice about this is
that there was this GeoMap
visualization on the top, but
then there's this time control
on the bottom.
And we built it in a very
generic way, so you could
pretty much plug and play
between any visualization that
you would like on the top, and
the independent time selector
on the bottom.
And Riccardo will talk a bit
about selectors later on, and
hopefully this will be available
by our next release.
OK so, other new things that
we've been working on.
So we completely redesigned
our website.
I encourage you all to go to
code.google.com/apis/chart/.
So we kind of unified the two
APIs that we previously had
there and we're releasing a new
version of our data source
library in Java.
So you could easily hook up any
data source that you have
in your backend to create
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
tables in the client.
And I mentioned earlier on that
Fusion Tables are now an
official, compliant
data source.
So you could hook up your
visualizations to any Fusion
Table that you might have. And
we're, almost on a weekly
basis, releasing new charts and
new visualizations that
you could start playing
around with.
And then you could see this
candlestick chart, and many
others that are coming out
in the next few weeks.
Cool.
So now, the grand winner
of our Unique
competition is Tom J.
Could you raise your hand?
Is Tom J.
here?
Are you Tom J.?
No.
Could you stand up?
Could you come over?
So, lower your expectations
as you step by, OK?
Now lower them a bit more.
You get a T-shirt.
Not anything more sophisticated
than that, but
congratulations.
Now what's cool about this is
that, you know, you see this
projected here.
But if each and every one of you
could look into your email
right now, you see that you got
a chart sent over to you
with live results of how
unique you were.
So if you chose three, probably
you're not very unique.
You're one of nine.
If you chose six, you're
the winner.
Congratulations, Tom.
And now I'll switch over to Amit
who will explain how we
were able, as the talk went on,
to send out all of these
emails, using the Google
App Scripts.
AMIT WEINSTEIN: Thank
you, Michael.
So my name is Amit Weinstein,
and I'm a software engineer in
the Google Chart Tools team.
And let's talk about Google app
scripts and how we sent
you all these emails.
So most of you are probably
familiar with the Google apps
script, but just in a few words,
Google apps script is a
framework to run code, script,
in the Google cloud.
So you have the benefit of
Google running the scripts for
you, at the time that you
specify, or according to
triggers that you define
in advance.
And it has the resources that
Google has, so you can access
your email, you can access
your calendar,
you can access Docs.
And in that example that we
showed, we sent you an email
to all the players that
played the game.
And how is this related
to charts?
So until today, you couldn't
actually create charts inside
the Google [? apps ?]
framework.
But it's something that
is very natural.
So if I have a Google
spreadsheet with all the
inventory that I have in
my store, for example.
And I want to, every week, to
get an email summarizing the
inventory and what happened
this week.
How much did I sell, and how
much is left in the inventory.
Then it's very natural for me
to ask for such a script.
And it's really easy to write
such a script if I had support
for charts in the framework.
So coming up pretty soon you
would have built-in support
for charts in the Google
Apps Scripts platform.
What does it mean?
You will be able to collect the
data as you already do in
the Google Apps Scripts.
So you have the spreadsheets
maybe from your email, so you
collect all the data, and
you create the chart.
And you customize the chart
according to whatever you want
the chart to look like, as
we will see in a minute.
And then you embed that chart
whenever you want.
So one option is to send the
chart as a separate image into
your email, as we did
in the example.
But there are other examples,
such as any adding the chart
into your doc list, so you can
just see all the statistics
from each week you will have an
additional item in your doc
list with the new chart.
So you can look at the flow that
we have in our case, we
have spreadsheets, which
stores all the data.
And you submitted the form as
we gave you the link today.
So the form answers are
aggregated into a spreadsheet
and then the script
was triggered.
So you can trigger the script
by form submission, for
example, or to define it
at a specific time.
And then the script just ran
over the votes that you
submitted and created
individual
charts for each player.
So the chart that you saw before
was a chart specific
for the control group
number three.
So it showed that
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE]
chose three, and the winner
chose six, and how is the
distribution of the other
players in the game.
So let's take a look at
some code snippets.
So the first part is collecting
the data.
I won't get that too much into
it, because this is part of
the Google apps general
framework and if you're
interested, there just a talk
in room two just following
this talk about that framework
in general.
So let's assume that I already
have the data, so I create a
new data table.
Michael already mentioned that
we have some protocol to shift
data from one place to another,
and to fit it to a
visualization.
And I just create a
new data table.
And I fill in the values that
I had from the Google
spreadsheet.
So I add different columns
according to the series that I
need to have in my chart.
Once I have the date
ready, I want to
create the charge itself.
So I initialize a new
column chart.
And I customize a chart
according to what I need.
So one important thing
is to fit the data
itself into the chart.
So this can be done using the
set data table method.
And the other thing, I can
customize the chart as I want.
For example, I can set the
dimensions, I can set the
title, and eventually just
build the chart.
And now I have a
chart instant.
And the question, what do I
do with the chart instant.
We have several options.
I our example we
sent an email.
So in order to send an
attachment in an email, I
first convert the chart
into PNG image.
So I can get the bytes of the
PNG image using this line.
And then I just attach to the
email and send it to each
different user.
So that's about it.
It's a very small script,
short script.
And it's very easy.
And hopefully in a few weeks,
you will be able to play with
it in your own rule abstracts.
So the next topic that I want
to cover is ChartWrapper.
So the point of ChartWrapper
that we introduced in the
release that we shipped
yesterday is
making things simpler.
So let's take a look at the
example of loading a Google
visualization without
using ChartWrapper.
So we have several sections
in our page.
The first one is loading
the visualization API.
So here I write Google
load visualization.
And I ask for a version,
number one.
And I specify the package that
they want, specifically here I
ask for [UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE]
package.
And then I have [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
method.
And assuming that I want the
data to come from the Google
spreadsheets, I have
some specific
spreadsheets URL that l query.
And I send that query.
And I specify the handler
to be run when
the query is returned.
And the handler makes sure that
the query was successful,
that there was no error, and
assuming there was no error, I
have a data table
from the query.
And I just initialize the
chart, and draw it.
So let's see how we can make
this snippet a bit shorter.
So this is a new snippet
with ChartWrapper.
So first I load the
visualization API without
specifying any specific chart.
I only want the core part of
the API, only what contains
ChartWrapper.
And then once I have the core
API, it just initializes a
ChartWrapper, and I
specify all the
parameters that I need.
So I specify the data source
URL, which is the same URL
from the previous slide.
I specify what chart type I
want to present, which is
column chart.
And then I specify the container
ID, where in the
page I want to display
the chart.
And that's it.
My next call is to
the Draw method.
And this handles all
things for me.
So it loads the correct package
from the visualization
API dynamically.
It sends the query to Google
spreadsheet without me having
to specify--
to query it myself.
And it then draws the
visualization into the view
that I specified.
In addition, it also allows
you to modify
the chart very easily.
So now let's say I want to
change the chart form from
column chart to area chart.
I adjust chart type
with area chart.
And for example, I can also set
some option like the title
to be, My New Area Chart.
And to call the draw
method again.
So everything is taken care
of behind the scenes.
So the new package is being
loaded, and the new chart is
being initialized and drawn
to the [? supreme. ?]
So we already discussed some
of the features of
ChartWrapper.
Here is a list of some more.
So we saw that we created from
JSON that has all the
information that the
chart needed.
Basically, encapsulated the
information that represents a
chart that we draw later
on the screen.
It loads the packages for us,
and it runs a query for us,
provides the handler.
We can easily modify and
redraw the chart.
And another feature that we
haven't discussed so far, is
that this object is serialized
and clone-able.
So basically once we have that
ChartWrapper, and we modify
it, we can store it.
And we can store it so that the
next time we want to show
the chart, we would be able
to show the unmodified
version of the chart.
So we can hold a state.
And one more thing that in order
to make life easier, we
have a function named
GoogleVisualization creates
snippets that takes the JSON
format of the ChartWrapper,
and create a snippet that you
can embed in your site.
So I can modify the chart
dynamically, and then take the
snippet of the chart and
embed it in whatever
web page that I want.
And we will now see an example
how this encapsulation helps
us to work with the
visualization API.
So the next topic
is Chart Editor.
So Michael only showed the Chart
Editor inside the Google
Spreadsheet environment.
But sometimes you have the data
outside of the Google
Spreadsheet environment, and
freely want to allow your
users, or even yourself, to
easily modify the chart and
customize it.
So the Chart Editor's a powerful
tool for customizing
the charts.
So we already saw some
of the features.
And as of today, you can
embed the Chart Editor
inside your own pages.
So for example, we embedded the
Editor inside the slide on
this doc, so I can just
click the open Editor.
And [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
and I have the data from the
game that we played before,
the live game from the results
that you submitted.
And I have it here.
And I can modify the chart.
So if Tom would say what
is his favorite color.
Let me see.
Is he here?
OK, so let's say we want to
change the color of the
winner, and let's say that his
favorite color is pink.
Then I choose pink, and
then I press OK.
And then the chart is embedded
inside these slides.
And it's persistent.
So now when I go back to
the slide, the color
would remain modified.
And I can modify the chart
again, and I can change, for
example, the title
and say, specify
the name of the winner.
And it's immediately reflected
to the slide that we see.
So you can embed your Editor
inside your own page.
OK so here is a very short
concept on how to create this
on your own.
So first we create
a ChartWrapper.
As we said, the ChartWrapper
encapsulates the information
that the visualization needs
in order to be drawn.
And in this case, we only
specify the data source URL
because everything else will be
defined by the user in the
Chart Editor.
So we don't need to specify the
options, and we don't need
to specify the container
at this time.
And we don't need to specify
the chart type.
Everything will be defined
in the Editor.
And the next step is to
create the Editor.
So we initialize a Google
visualization
Chart Editor object.
And we listen to the OK event.
So we want to decide what
happens when the user clicks
on the event button in the
Chart Editor window.
And in this example, we take
the Editor, and we ask the
Editor for the current,
up-to-date ChartWrapper
instance, which has
the serialized
representation of the chart.
And we just call the draw method
to the container that
we specify.
And that's it.
The chart is immediately updated
and is persistent.
And then we just need
to open the dialogue
whenever you want.
So we decided that it would be
open on the click on the open
dialog button that you can have
whatever trigger that you
want to open the Editor.
That's it.
Now I will hand over to Riccardo
to tell you about
Controls and Dashboards.
RICCARDO GOVONI: Welcome,
everybody.
My name is Riccardo, and I'm
going to guide you through the
last part of this presentation,
which is going
to be Controls and Dashboards.
So, before we start, let
me spend a minute
with a small story.
How many times has it happened
to you that you tried to solve
a problem using a chart, and
if you're [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
it would only solve part
of the problem.
It would only give you
a partial answer.
For example, a few weeks back,
my manager came around and he
asked me, can you show me the
number of bugs that a team
created over the last week.
And I said, OK, here is a pie
chart, number of bugs created
over the last week
by the team.
He was happy, went away, came
back five minutes later and
said, can you also show me
the trend over time.
I said, OK.
I aggregated the data
over time, then
created a line chart.
He was happy, went away.
Came back five minutes later
and asked me again, can you
show me the data maybe
aggregated
over months and year.
OK, two more pie charts,
month and year.
Should be fine.
Went away, came back.
And, can I see the data also
aggregated maybe by geography
because your team is distributed
and you have
people all over the place and
I want to see the bugs that
they created in other places?
OK, go through the data
again, aggregate by
geography this time.
Sum everything up.
Put a GeoChart in place.
And he was happy,
but I was not.
By this time, I was reasonably
annoyed because I created a
very sketch dashboard with logic
to keep everything in
place, and everything was a bit
of Javascript nightmare.
Why was that?
Well for two reasons.
One is that, today,
visualizations are helpful,
but they offer a single
perspective.
You have to choose one or a few
of dimensions out of all
the data that you might have,
out of the data table that you
might have, and it might span
multiple dimensions, and use
them for your chart, right?
And in a pie chart, you can
only pick one dimension.
And maybe the dimension does not
give you the full picture.
It only gives you a partial
presentation of the data that
you have.
The other issue is that so far
wiring together multiple
visualizations has been hard.
You had to take care of all the
events, making sure that
all of the visualizations
were ready.
And maybe taking care of
distributing the correct data
to each visualization, because
they have different rules for
the kind of columns
that they expect.
And so, so far it
has been hard.
And you had write a lot of
JavaScript boilerplate.
And in the end, I mean, it's
not really that fun.
And so we thought, can
we make anything--
can we do anything to
make this simpler?
And we thought about
it for a while.
And at least to make my life
simpler, so I don't have to
create that many dashboards
for my code, we decided to
introduce two entities.
The first one is a control.
Well what is a Control A control
is a UI widget that
collects user input and uses
that information to decide
which data to hand over to
the charts that followed.
So for example, a control could
be an auto-completer, a
slider, a data picker, range
selector, you name it.
And that will let you the
user specify and give us
information about the
data that he wants
to see in the charts.
And here you see an example of
the gallery of widgets that
we're going to roll out as
part of the controls and
dashboard APIs.
And as you can see here, we
have sliders, we have
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
pickers, we have
auto-completers.
You can imagine, for example,
having a data chart and a
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
slider on top of that.
And let the user, with the
slider, select the fraction of
the data that he cares about,
and he might be more
interested in.
So now you need to wire
everything together, and for
this we're introducing
a dashboard.
What is a dashboard?
A dashboard is just a collection
of controls and
charts that play together
over the same set
of underlying data.
It's the wiring, it's the
binding logic, so that you
don't have to, that takes care
of basically propagating the
data through all the controls
and charts that are part of
the dashboard and making
them behave like a
[? query info. ?]
So let's look at how the
API would look like.
So we tried to keep the API
simple, and thus similar to
the ones that you're already
familiar with.
Well what would you do then?
Well, the first thing is we
said, they're going to
probably create some charts.
And for this, they're going to
use the google.visualiza
tion.ChartWrapper that
Amit just introduced.
And as we said, it's a single,
self-contained wrapper that
describes what the
chart should be.
It has a type, for example,
a pie chart,
there's some options.
And it has a place older
in the page that
would contain it.
Then you're going to have
controls that will let the
user play with the data,
and affect the charts.
And for this, we're going
to introduce--
we're introducing now--
an equivalent class which
has the same semantics--
google.visualiza
tion.ControlWrapper.
It is configured in the same
way with a JSON object, and
you use that to specify the
kind of controls that you
would like to have. In this
case, we are introducing a
control of type number range
filter, which is going to be a
slider, a range selector
over numbers.
And it's going to have
a few options.
It's going to work on the
data table column,
which is called, salary.
It is going to limit the
range from 10 to 100.
If you don't specify it, it will
figure itself out from
the data that you gave it.
And it has a container where
it's going to render itself.
Then you need to wire
the two together.
And for this, we're
going to use
google.visualization.dashboard.
And as you can see, it
has a bind method.
And in the bind method, you
specify the controls and the
charts that will be part
of your visualization.
Controls first, charts second.
The dashboard will take care
of everything for you.
So it will take care of wiring
all of the events of
propagating the data through
all of the elements, making
sure everybody gets
the right data.
And finally while clearly we
need the data at some point.
So until now, you were used
to giving the data
to the chart itself.
But now we have a dashboard
that props everything up.
And so you're going to give
the data to the dashboard
through a familiar
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
method.
And so in the end, what you have
is a hopefully short and
simple API that will let you
specify a dashboard, which is
a composition of controls and
charts and [UNINTELLIGIBLE],
with letter table
that you have.
So let's recap a bit.
As we said, we have introduced
the google.visualiza
tion.ChartWrapper as a single,
self-contained descriptor for
what the chart should
look like.
We have the google.visualiza
tion.ControlWrapper, single
self-contained descriptor
for what the
control should look like.
And again, it is a user
interface element that
collects the user input, and
uses it to decide which data
goes to the charts.
As you can see, again, it has a
type that decides which kind
of control you want to have, a
placeholder for the position
in the page, where you want to
render it in, [? pairs ?]
options, the edition
is the state.
State describes basically the
user input that we collected.
For our range slider, it would
describe the position and the
value of the two
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
of the range slider.
You can define an initial
state, so if you want to
prepare the control in the
defined state when you
initialize the dashboard.
And it can also-- it change
after the fact,
programmatically, for example,
to integrate
with your own logic.
And then we have the
google.visualization.dashboard
and simple constructor, a bind
method where you specify which
controls are part of the
dashboard, which charts are
part of the dashboard, and we
will take care of wiring
everything together.
It also as a method--
it also lets you drop--
sorry, bind together controls
with other controls to create
sort of the dependency chains.
And we will go over this
later if we have time.
And finally, you have
draw method that
accepts a data table.
And once you give the data table
to the dashboard, then
the entire dashboard
will go live.
And it would work on its own
from that point onward.
Whenever the user will interact
with a control, the
dashboard will take care of
updating all the affected jobs
and keeping the old
page coherent.
But enough with the slides, and
let's see if we can cover
it with a demo.
So many of you are familiar with
this data site that was,
I think, originally presented
by Rosling, and shows the
correlation between life
expectancy kids per woman.
Not many?
OK.
For those of you that are not,
this was a great presentation
that showed basically a life
expectancy and number of kids
per women, change over time, for
all the countries in the
world and showed basically the
world evolved to where
countries where people lived
longer and because of having
fewer kids.
It's a very powerful
presentation--
visualization.
But it's monolithic, right?
You cannot really change
and [? doubt ?]
the radius.
It's kind of a flash component,
where, suppose you
want to change the bubble chart
with a GeoMap, or with a
different kind of
visualization.
Or suppose you want to present
another kind of information
along with this bubble
chart as the time
slider moves along.
It's not really easy to
change this chart.
I cannot actually
do it right now.
But maybe we can create
something similar with the
APIs that we just introduced.
Let's see if we can build
something like
this, not this one.
So ideally, what we would like
to assemble in the next few
minutes is something
like this one.
You see on the top, we have
a bunch of controls.
We have a year selector, we have
a country selector, we
have a life expectancy slider.
And whenever you operate one
of the controls, all the
charts in the bottom will
react in real time.
In this case we are showing
different metrics, for
example, life expectancy and
GDP per capita, which is an
indication of how rich
were the people on
average in that country.
So for example, for 2008, if
you look at which countries
have a life expectancy below
60 years, you will see that
unfortunately most of Africa
sill has a low life
expectancy.
But at the same time, you have
seen how the charts and
everything updated in
real time when the
user applied the control.
So let's try and build
something like that.
So the first thing we're
going to start
with is with the data.
The data that we are using is a
selection of basically here,
country name, GDP for that
country, and life expectancy
over a range of 40 years for
different countries.
This is a data set that I have
prepared beforehand, and it's
stored in a data
table locally.
So on the left, you can see
that we are visualizing it
using a ChartWrapper.
We are specifying that the type
is going to be a table.
We have a container, because
there is the element that it's
going to contain the chart in
a webpage, the data, a few
options, and the draw method.
So far, so good.
So let's change it a bit.
On the right, now you see that
I've added a control.
A year--
basically a category
picker for year.
And whenever I operate the
control, so let's move to the
'60s, the data on the
bottom changes.
So here we are saying, data from
the '60s, move to '77,
and we've got the data
from year '77.
And let's go over this code
on the left side.
So again, we have the
ChartWrapper on top, for the
table, as we said before.
Here in the middle, you see a
ControlWrapper instance that
says I'm going to use
the [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
filter.
It's going to apply itself
on the column,
which is named here.
It has a few options for
the user interface.
It says, will it allow multiple
entries or not?
Will it allow the user to type
something in an auto-completer
fashion or not?
It used to have the initial
selected year as 2008.
And then we have a dashboard
instance.
Create a dashboard instance, and
as I demonstrated to you
before, you kill the
bind method.
You tell that you want the year
selector to affect the
chart, and then you call draw
with the data table.
From this point onward, whenever
I operate the year
selector, but chart updates.
But a simple table is not really
that helpful for our
case, so let's try and change
it to something else.
So what we're going to do is
change it to a pie chart.
We're going to change
the options.
So we're going to say that the
width is going to be 500
pixels and 500 pixels.
And the slide's visibility
threshold--
sorry, a bit boring--
is going to be 160, because
we don't slides
that are too small.
We're going to use the view
option to say which columns we
want from the data table.
Since a pie chart only allows
you to pick two columns.
We're going to use column
one, country name,
and column two, GDP.
And that's pretty much it.
And we just redraw it, and
we got the pie chart now.
So let's move back
to the sixties,
the pie chart updates.
What was a good place where
we should have been
living in the '60s?
Well, the United States seem
pretty good, big slice.
Here we are representing the
GDP, so, how much money the
average person used to
have in the '60s.
Luxembourg, pretty good.
What about the '80s?
Where do you think we should
have been living in the '80s?
Any idea?
Who said that?
Monaco!
Good choice.
But as you can see, the pie
chart itself is still a bit
confused, right?
There are too many slices and
not really very helpful.
So let's add another control.
It would be nice if we could
let the user choose the
country and select between
multiple countries.
So we're going to copy
this control here.
There we go.
And we're going to introduce a
new control over the country.
So we're going to call
it, country.
It will still be a
category filter.
We'll call it, country.
We'll work on the column which
is called country name.
And, for a change, let the
user type something in.
Allow multiple choices.
We don't really care about
the initial state.
OK, we defined a new control,
here, using the control
wrapper object that
we described.
And next, the only thing that
we're going to say is, OK,
when both the country or the
year control are operated by
the user, please update
the chart.
OK, good enough.
Let's move back to
the '60s again.
We got a category picker here,
with all the nations here.
Since we specified that it
should work from the country
name column, and the country
name column contains all the
countries, it's already
auto-populated itself with all
the countries that it could
find over there.
And so we can say, I don't
know, in the '60s, China
versus Thailand.
Wealth distribution seems
to be pretty equal.
Let's move to the '80s.
Thailand got over.
You can start adding
countries--
United States, United
Kingdom, et cetera.
And you get the picture.
You see how the charts
update in real time.
From this point onward, well,
it's only a matter of adding a
lot more charts, and more
controls, and using the same
simple logic that I already
described to you.
Create a ChartWrapper, create
a ControlWrapper--
one for the charts, one
for the controls--
create a dashboard, and use
the dashboard to bind
everything together.
And you should be able to
get to this final result
reasonably quickly.
And this, from this point
onward, is just a matter of
applying, right?
So for example, you could say,
let me show only the countries
that have a life expectancy over
70 years, and let's look
how we change it over time.
In the '60s, all in the Nordic
countries and Canada.
In the '70s, America's come in,
Australia, most of Europe.
In the '80s, strengthen
their position.
In the '90s, South
America comes in.
2008, a lot of countries
have a life
expectancy over 70 years.
Southern Africa is
still missing.
And so you can see how easy
it is to combine together
multiple charts and control and
assemble an interactive
dashboard out of that.
OK.
So good.
So these are controls
and dashboards.
Word of warning, they are an
experimental package that we
are rolling out--
we actually rolled
it out yesterday.
So they are in version 1.1.
So when you load the Google
visualization API, saying
google.load/visualization and
you specify a version number,
use version 1.1 if you
want the controls.
Being experimental, they might
break and change over time,
but we are very interested in
learning from you-- what you
think they should be, or what
you think they should be, what
you think we should do on top of
them, what kind of features
they should have, and whatnot.
So please, give them a try.
We're going to listen
to your feedback.
We have some ideas on our
own, but give them a
try, and let us know.
And that's pretty much it.
So for all the four topics that
we covered, starting from
consumer, create your own
charts, tricks, spreadsheets,
the integration for enterprise
with app script, and finally
for developers with controls
and dashboards.
The main communication
link is over there:
code.google.com/apis/charts.
We rolled out the brand new
version of the documentation
yesterday, and we are now
open for Q and A.
So if the police want to come
back, any questions that you
might have.
AUDIENCE: [APPLAUSE]
Have you guys thought about
hooking up, instead of passing
the data table, passing
it a data source.
So I'm not sure if you've seen
things like Spotfire where you
actively, dynamically slide
in your running queries
essentially in the background.
Is that something that
you guys are
planning for in the future?
RICCARDO GOVONI: You mean
for the dashboard thing?
AUDIENCE: Yep.
Having a control, actually,
maybe control
a data source API.
RICCARDO GOVONI: Yes, so
version 1 is local data
source, but version 2.x
is going to remodel
the sources as well.
AUDIENCE: Do you plan on
releasing some of the extra
features from the annotated
timeline from Google Finance?
AMIT WEINSTEIN: Yeah, so the
control that Michael showed
today, that you can select the
time range dynamically is one
step in the direction of
creating an HTML5 version of
the annotated timeline charts.
We are heading there.
AUDIENCE: So things like real
time updates will be
available, and that
kind of stuff?
AMIT WEINSTEIN: I didn't hear.
AUDIENCE: Like real
time updates from
the annotated timeline?
AMIT WEINSTEIN: We will send an
email to the group in the
next few [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
that we add another component
on the way to
enriching the chart.
AUDIENCE: Hi, as I understand
correctly, we don't have a way
to connect to a database, and
run a query and create a
chart, right?
AMIT WEINSTEIN: You can
create the data
table locally if you--
AUDIENCE: Locally, but with a
query that's just for it?
AMIT WEINSTEIN: No, no, you
can create the data table
without any query, just
in Javascript.
AUDIENCE: OK I can
use something
else to load the data.
But in the future need you may
have a version which would run
the queries live and
create charts?
Did I understand
that correctly?
AMIT WEINSTEIN: I think I don't
understand the question.
AUDIENCE: A person before me
asked that question, that you
could run a query, or line of
running queries and creating
charts at the same time.
I'm more concerned about
enterprise applications where
you have large databases and
you don't have smaller data
sets, so what would the utility
in such applications?
AMIT WEINSTEIN: OK so the new
data source library that we
submitted a little while
back allowed you
to sample the data.
So if you have a
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
data source which is big, we
added some capabilities to the
query language to allow
it to sample it.
And currently the dashboard only
works with a local data
table, so we have to
store all the data
locally in you browser.
But in the future version, we
hope that we would be able to
connect to remote data sources
and combining with sampling,
every time that you narrow
your view, you
would use less sampling.
So a chart would remain with a
reasonable amount of data, and
it would reflect the
current slice that
you are looking for.
AUDIENCE: How easy is it going
to be to customize a team of
the [? skin ?]
of this, of the dashboard
and the tools?
RICCARDO GOVONI: So hopefully
it should be easy.
If you go through the APIs,
you will see that they all
have a consistence with
standard API.
You create an instance of the
kind of thing you want, a
chart, a control, or a
dashboard, you configure it
with some standard options.
And then you just draw it.
And it's very--
sorry, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: So something like,
a scattered chart to have a
custom background or something
like that, is that possible?
Or does it all have to be
solid colors for now?
RICCARDO GOVONI: You can
customize, I think you can
customize the background
as well, already.
AMIT WEINSTEIN: So there are
two different things.
Customizing the chart is
something that we provide as
part of the chart.
So every chart has its own
customization options.
And you can send us an email
if you need some other
customizations if they're
currently not there.
And I think that Riccardo, he
meant that controllers,
hopefully in the future, you
would be able to create your
own controller that blends more
smoothly in your page to
interact with the chart
that you provide.
AUDIENCE: Hi, I still
have questions
about the data source.
What data source options are
there currently for this?
And what options maybe in the
future will you guys be
looking at?
AMIT WEINSTEIN: There are
several data sources that
already exist today.
So one example is Google
Spreadsheet, another is Fusion
Tables, and it's
also by Google.
I think there's also Salesforce,
data is provided
as a Google Fusion
data source.
And you can create your
own data source.
We have open source libraries
in several languages,
including Java and Python,
that you can create.
If you have the data stored in
your location, you can just
include our code, and become
a proper data source.
If you have the data in a
specific place, you can just
plug in our library.
If you have it in some third
party that doesn't support the
data source API, then I guess
the only option is to ask them
to support it.
AUDIENCE: Just a quick question
about the interface
with the dashboard.
You know with current charts you
have some events that are
kicked off when you select a
data series or when you click
on a data point, are those
events going to be able to
kick off things in other parts
of the chart the way you guys
have implemented it?
RICCARDO GOVONI: Right, so if
I understand correctly, the
question is whether interaction
on a specific
chart would propagate to the
rest of the dashboard.
Again, not in the experimental
version that
we're rolling out.
But one of, basically, the
first pictures that we're
going to roll out is the fact,
for example, that when you
select a specific data point
in a chart, like we've
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
representation of that
to the point,
across the entire dashboard.
So if it's a country, maybe the
country in the GeoMap will
be highlighted as well.
So for example, the selection
event will propagate across
the dashboard.
AUDIENCE: So you guys might have
gone through this stuff a
little quickly, so I might
be wrong, but then the
interactions on the
dashboards--
you know, the controls for the
past parameters, or whatever,
filters to the charts--
that's hardwired together,
right?
You wire a controlled
two-way chart.
Is there some sort of more loose
type coupling you guys
were thinking of, like
event-to-run mechanisms or
something, just so you can do a
bit more easily, instead of
hard-wiring it all together?
RICCARDO GOVONI: So under the
scenes, it's all event-based,
and asynchronous, so the bind
method that you see is
basically shortcut, shorthand to
wire everything up quickly.
But at the moment, it's already
a sort of fairly
detached model.
I'm not sure what kind of--
you would like an event-based
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]?
AUDIENCE: It might be right.
In this case, I guess, if you
have a country name, and if
there's a bunch of charts and
I'm looking for country name,
if the control is filtering on a
country name, all the charts
just kind of obey it, right?
Yeah, so then that's great.
I just wanted to
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
RICCARDO GOVONI: Yeah, so by
the bind method, you can
specify any number of jobs.
You can do one-to-one,
one-to-many, many-to-one.
So you can have one control
driving 10 charts or no--
AUDIENCE: Can you have a click
on a chart drive other
elements on the page,
right now?
Like if I were to select say,
Australia, on one of the
charts, like the map, can I
actually have, instead of
selecting Australia from a
control, can the chart itself
behave like a control?
RICCARDO GOVONI: We are about
to have something similar.
Maybe I can go back
1,000 slides.
The time selector control
that Michael showed
up initially, maybe--
it's certainly not this
slide too fast.
OK, this one.
So you see this one on the
bottom is a control that lets
you choose, in this case it's
a time interval, and it's
built on top of an underlying
line chart.
So there's already the concept
of combining controls with a
specific chart.
We may not have, right out of
the box, the kind of control
over a GeoMap that you are
talking about, but there's
already something like that.
Good.
Anything else?
Then we're good.
AMIT WEINSTEIN: Thank
you very much.